I have the number 210 let's try to
factor this into prime numbers so 210 is
2 times 3 times 5 times 7 it's the
product of the first 4 prime numbers
this is its unique prime factorization
and one of these prime numbers these are
numbers that can't be factored into
smaller numbers and we leave one out of
the game because it's special and so the
prime numbers are 2 3 5 7 11 13 17 19
can they go on forever as was proved
maybe 2300 years ago by Euclid now one
thing that you can obviously see about
these Prime's
is that after 2 they're all odd numbers
that means that except for 2 if you add
two points together you get an even
number so the two plants could even be
the same prime so for example I got 3
plus 3 equals 6 I get 3 plus 5 equals 8
I get let's see 3 plus 7 equals 10 and
also have that the same as 5 plus 5 so
10 has two representations as a sum of
two primes there's a conjecture of
Goldbach from the 18th century and every
even numbers starting with 6 is the sum
of two odd primes and I should state
this with a question 1 it's not known
we've been novels written about the
quest for proving this conjecture or
Goldbach we don't know the answer my
friends who are n League number theorist
we died to prove Goldbach's conjecture
meaning is would be a great prize agree
cout we strongly suspect that the answer
is yes and why do we suspect so well
because the primes are very numerous
even though they thin out
they are very numerous and so a given
even number has a lot of chances to be
the sum of two primes
210 as you can quickly see is an even
number and Goldbach would predict that
it's the summer to bronze in fact it's
not only the sum of two primes
it's the sum of two points in a lot of
ways in a champion number of ways so
what I mean by that if if you're going
to write 200 in technique as P plus Q
where P is less than or equal to Q and P
and Q are prime numbers and Q is greater
than or equal to 105 so let's take what
QB any prime with 105 less than or equal
to Q less than or equal to 210 okay any
prime whatsoever and now let's look at
210 minus Q what can you tell me about
that number that number is less than or
equal to 105 105 being kapha q10 and Q
is above the halfway 210 minus Q is not
divisible by 2 how do I know that
because 210 is divisible by 2 and Q is a
prime and it's bigger than or equal to
105 so we thought okay it's not
divisible by 3 how do I know that
because 3 is a divisor of 210 and Q
being a prime and bigger than or equal
to 105 is not divisible by tween and
also this number is not divisible by 5
or 7 for the same reasons
since 210 is 2 times 3 times 5 times 7
so this number does not have as point
factors 2 3 5 & 7 so what is its least
possible prime factor well it would be
the next prime after 7 which is a little
loving so if this is a composite number
you will have to be some prime greater
than or equal to 11 times something else
bigger than 1 but the least candidate at
11 times 11 which is 121 which is bigger
than 105 so we conclude
at 210 minus Q is 1 or chronic and it's
not 1 and how do I know it's not 1
well if it were one that would mean that
Q is 209 and Q is not equal to 209 this
209 is not a prime is 11 times 19 so
every prime Q between 105 and 210 gives
us a P such that P plus Q equals 210 so
Goldbach is not only right about the
number of 210 he's really right about
the number 210 and in fact you can ask
how special is this property the 210 has
its the last number with this problem so
let's look at all these Prime's between
105 and 210 here they are look at them
every one of them is a candidate for
writing to channes the sum of two primes
and if it works then 210 minus one of
these Prime's
will itself be a prime is there a
pairing for each one of these Prime's
with a prime smaller than or equal to
105 and we find 210 is the very last
case where this ever happens if this
happen for a few smaller cases so for
example for the number 36
[Music]
it works ok that's boring 36 is small
210 is you know getting up there and it
works for 210 ok doesn't work at all for
any number bigger than 210 and this is
proven and this is approved theorem and
I can even tell you the names of the
people that proved it it was done in
1993 and the authors were jean-marc Dez
VA Andrew Granville
Vladislav nakiye vich and myself
professor I'm going to call 210 very
gold Bucky very gold Bucky
that's an excellent name Brady I like it
20 years 11 and 11 22 and you can see as
it goes down I sort of fill things out
now what you don't see from this picture
so well is it actually as the numbers
get big there are really a lot of ways
of writing a numbers and sum of two
primes